hola andrés pues la arquidiócesis de
medellín tendrá que entregar la
información que le solicite en febrero
de 2021 sobre 915 sacerdotes según los
indicios de la investigación
periodística e investigación que vengo
haciendo hace cuatro años en la
arquidiócesis de medicina entre el 20 y
el 30 por ciento de los sacerdotes han
abusado sexualmente de niños niñas y
adolescentes con base de esos indicios
fue que le pedí nuevamente información
al arzobispo de medellín quien ya estaba
obligado a entregar esta información
porque en 2020 ya la corte
constitucional de colombia le había
ordenado responder las peticiones que
enviaran los periodistas preguntando por
este tema monseñor ricardo tobón no
quiso responder por estos 915 sacerdotes
y es por eso que nuevamente el arqui de
la corte constitucional
interviene y le da 48 horas para que
entregue la información que estaba
solicitando desde hace un año ahora qué
garantías hay de que se proporcione toda
la información completa y además
correcta que usted solicita
pues no entregarla implicaría que
monseñor está incurriendo en un delito
que es el delito de falsedad ideológica
en documento privado
en otros países del mundo la iglesia
católica ha reconocido que esa
información ha destruido la ha quemado
es el caso de alemania en alemania los
obispos salieron y dijeron ya esa
información no existe y es muy probable
que eso no exista aquí en colombia en
medellín en bogotá en cali en sonsón
rionegro otras diócesis del país con las
cuales tengo una disputa legal para que
entreguen estos archivos el hecho es que
aquí ya hay una orden de jueces
constitucionales y si bien los obispos
de colombia creen que el derecho
canónico está por encima del derecho
ordinario pues vamos a ver qué reacción
toma ahora el arzobispo cuando es el
máximo tribunal el que por segunda vez
en dos años está ordenando entregar esta
información repito si no la entrega
estaría incurriendo en un delito y los
jueces de la república hasta podrían
ordenar su arresto o sancionarlo porque
aquí estamos hablando de un estado de
derecho como es colombia en el cual
los jueces se tienen que acatar como
pablo usted ha escrito ya dos libros al
respecto que espera lograr con esta
nueva información
y este esta nueva sentencia de la corte
constitucional la segunda en dos años
nos allana el camino para investigar
desde vorágine que es el medio de
comunicación en el que trabajo el
archivo secreto de todas las diócesis y
arquidiócesis y comunidades religiosas
de colombia con esta nueva sentencia
llegaremos a todas las diócesis del país
y le reclamaremos a todos los obispos de
colombia el archivo secreto no tienen
que hacer porque las preguntas que estoy
haciendo las preguntas que voy a hacer
son muy similares a las preguntas que la
corte constitucional y ha dicho a la
arquidiócesis de medellín que no tienen
reserva que tienen que responder que
tienen que entregar esa información pues
estamos hablando nada más y nada menos
que de violencia sexual contra niños
niñas y adolescentes y aquí en colombia
el artículo 44 de la constitución
protege primordialmente a los niños ya
las niñas cualquier otro derecho está
por debajo del derecho de los niños y
las niñas por ende llegaremos por medio
de esta investigación periodística
a todas las diócesis y arquidiócesis y
comunidades religiosas del país con esta
nueva sentencia de la corte
constitucional